انقذت الاقتصاد قبل قرن
وبواسطه الذكاء الاصطناعي للصن يسرق اكثر
من نصف مليون دولار
وتتابعون فقره 25 سؤال ما حننت واهلا بكم
الى تفاعلكم
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم يبدو النزلات الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن لم تنتهي بعد ولا نعلم ان كانت هذه
المره هي الاخيره ام لا لكن هذه الهفوه
ربما تكون مختلفه لان بطلاتها امراه ونطق
بها بايدن امام حشودا من الناس فخلال
احتفال التكريم رئيسه مجلس النواب السابقه
بعيدا عن دورها وانجازاتها وكيف قادت
المعركه لتمرير خطه انقاذ الامريكيه
وقانون البنيه التحتيه للحزبين وقانون خفض
التضخم ختام حديثه كان المفاجاه عندما قال
انها ساعدت في انقاذ الاقتصاد الامريكي في
فتره الكساد الكبير عام 1929
والناس الليله يبقى
[تصفيق]
كلامه
1929 يعني قبل 100 عام وخلال تلك الفتره
لم تكن نانسي بلوسي قد ولدت
في انقاذ امريكا خلال الكساد الاقتصادي
الكبير طبعا وسائل تواصل الاجتماعي سارعت
الى تلقف هذه الهفوه والتعليق عليها
والسخريه منها وتصدرت جمله هفوه جديده
لبايدن الاخبار والعناوين وكما يقال اسال
المراه عن اي شيء الا عن عمرها وحتى الان
لم يعرف موقف نانسيبي لوسي بعد ان اكتشفت
ان عداده عمرها بدا حتى قبل ان تولد
يوم بعد يوم يتزايد الحديث عن الذكاء
الاصطناعي ومخاطره والخوف من الاعتماد
عليه بشكل كامل في الحياه اليوميه للافراد
الجديد في هذا الخصوص تحضير من الرئيس
السابق للشبكه جوجل الذي قال ان الذكاء
الاصطناعي يمكن ان يشكل خطرا على حياه
الانسان حذر من ان تكون لديه القدره على
ايذاء او قتل العديد من الاشخاص في
المستقبل القريب بسبب تطور الكبير الذي
تشهده التكنولوجيا والتشكيك في عدم القدره
على احتوائها قال ان الاشرار سيكونون
مستعدين لاستعمال هذه الانظمه للقيام
بامور تضره بمصالح الكثير من الناس ويبدو
ان هذا ما بدا بالفعل فمن خلال تقنيه
الذكاء الاصطناعي استطاع شخص في الصين
الاحتيال على رجل الاعمال وسرقه نحو 600
الف دولار منه حيث قام الشاب بتغيير شكله
وصوته وجعله مشابها لصديق رجل اعمال غني
وقام باجراء مكالمه فيديو معه وطلب منه
مبلغا ماليا من اجل العمل وبالفعل قام
صديقه رجل الاعمال بتحويل المبلغ المطلوب
الى الشاب ومن بعدها قام بارسال رساله
لصديقه ليخبره انه تم تحويل المبلغ وعندما
تفاجا برده فعله ادرك انه تعرض لعمليه
احتيال
قام بابلاغ السلطات وتمكن من استعاده جزء
من المبلغ ولم يتم التعرف الى الان على
هويه الشاب الذي استغل تقنيه الذكاء
الاصطناعي من اجل السرقه
على كل ينضم الينا عبر من دبي انس المرعي
المختص في الشؤون المعلوماتيه والتقنيه
اهلا وسهلا بك معنا في العربيه وفي
تفاعلكم الذكاء الاصطناعي يتطور بشكل كبير
وبوتيره سريعه جدا بحسب الخبراء لدرجه انه
وصل الى حد تقليد صوت البشر والتحدث
بالنيابه عنه ما مدى خطوره هذه التقنيه
مساء الخير الك سهام ولجميع المشاهدين
بالفعل او الفيديو المزيف
كان
الخبراء يتحدث عنه قبل الاشهر وقبل سنوات
بانه راح يكون خطر على البشر وعلى حياتنا
وبالفعل هذا الشيء صعب ما بدنا نخوف الناس
بقدر ما نواعيهم اكثر بانه هذا الشيء
موجود جميع قنوات الاتصال في الدنيا تتعرض
الاستغلال من قبل
المخربين والناس اللي بيستخدموها بطريقه
اجراميه خلينا نقول
واجبنا نحن انه نتجنب هذا الشيء نكون
واعيين اكثر نوعي الاطفال نوعي الشباب
الصغار نوعي الكبار بالسن من هذا الخطا
كيف تتم هاي التكنولوجيا للاسف سهام اليوم
التكنولوجيا اصبحت متوفره وبايد الجميع
بمبلغ اقل من دولار في انا
اصنع شخصيه مماثله لشخصيتك تتحدث
للجمهور بنفس صوتي التقنيه موجوده اللي هي
الفويس سكن او الفويس كلون
بامكاننا نصنع شخصيه مشابهه لاي شخصيه
بدنا اياها انا مبسوط اني عم اشوف شركات
التكنولوجيا اللي بتقدم هاي الخدمات
عم تطلب منا معلومات اكثر قبل ان تنتج
الفيديو فمثلا انا لو طلبت فيديو الي رح
يتحققوا من
هويتي قبل ان ينتجوا هذا الفيديو هاي خطوه
بالاتجاه الصحيحه لكن المشكله يا انس هناك
تشكيك وهناك تحذير من خبراء تقنيه من عدم
امكانيه البشر في المستقبل القريب من
احتواء مخاطر الذكاء الاصطناعي وقد يصبح
الذكاء الاصطناعي اذكى من عقول البشر الى
اي مدى هذا وارد
انا ما بدي اناقش انه هل سيصبح اذكى من
البشر لكن
اذكر نفس الموضوع كان
يعني حديث الناس لما
ظهر الانترنت كان عم يقول هذا الانترنت
راح يخرب الدنيا راح
يزيد الجرائم وبالفعل لكن لو نظرنا وقارنا
بين الاشياء الايجابيه اللي جاب لنا اياها
الانترنت مقارنه بالاشياء السلبيه لوجدنا
انه ممكن الايجابي يفوق بالكثير انا يعني
تحدثنا على شاشتكم بانه موضوع الاخلاقيات
للذكاء الاصطناعي تحدثنا كثير عنه اليوم
في مؤتمرات في العالم عم تحكي عن هذا
الموضوع اليوم صار فيه دول
تقنن الذكاء الاصطناعي عم بيصير قانون
للذكاء الصناعي عم بيصير في تجريم
للاستخدامات غير
او للاستخدامات السلبيه والاستخدامات
الاجراميه
الذكاء الاصطناعي ليس يعني مثله مثل اي
تكنولوجيا فينا نستخدمها
بشكل سيء جدا وبشكل ايجابي
يتطلب الواعي الكبير بيتطلب القانون
بيتطلب
اليوم المشكله ليست في خطوره الذكاء
الاصطناعي فقط وعدم القدره على احتوائه
ولكن ان يتم استغلال الذكاء الاصطناعي
لاغراض خبيثه من قبل شخص اشخاص يعني سيئين
واشخاص قد يستخدمون الذكاء الاصطناعي
لاهداف غير سليمه ما مدى خطوره ذلك بالف
خطير جدا يعني بذكرني الموضوع بنفس قصه
فيسبوك لايت وكل اللايفات اللي على جميع
منصات التواصل اليوم صار في تقريبا تاخير
لمده بعض ثواني بين انه يظهر الفيديو يعني
بين الفيديو الواقع وبين الفيديو المبث
على الشبكات ليش هذا الكلام صار من بعد
الجريمه اللي حصلت فيه نيوزلندا قبل عامين
نعول على التكنولوجيا وعلى اصحاب
تكنولوجيا الذكاء الصناعي بانهم يصنعوا
لنا مثل هاي يعني
خلينا نقول البوابات حتى يتاكدوا من انه
انا شخص عم بتحدث بشيء ايجابي او ما في اي
استغلال للاخرين ولا في اي عمليات قد تكون
مضره باي شخص ممكن عم بيتلقى هذا الاتصال
او هذا الفيديو طيب انا
حدود اتصور الكبير الذي تشهده التكنولوجيا
وهل يمكن ان نصل الى وقت يعني يصير
الاعتماد على هذه التكنولوجيا
بشير كامل في حياتنا اليوميه
شوفي سهام بصراحه هو غير محدود يعني انا
اليوم انا عم حدثك الان في هذه الاثناء
بدي اصور نفسي واخلي الافاتار يصير يتحدث
عني في كثير من المواقف لحتى يوفر علي وقت
ويوفر ويكون انا متوفر اكثر من 24 ساعه
خلال اليوم هاي البدايه على فكره يعني اذا
لو تساليني عن النسبه بقلك البدايه هي
واحد بالميه فقط اليوم لسه نحن يا دوب
وصلنا واحد بالميه لسه امامنا الكثير من
التطور رح نشوف ونسمع اشياء ما كنا
نتوقعها
مثل ما حكيت لك صناعه التكنولوجيا
والقوانين ووعينا ثلاث اشياء ممكن تقلل من
مخاطر الديب فيك والذكاء الاصطناعي خصوصا
في موضوع الفيديو والحادثه الاخيره التي
سمعناها في الصين
هلا يا انس من دبي انس المرعي المختص في
الشؤون المعلوماتيه والتقنيه شكرا جزيلا
نبقى في المجال التكنولوجي فعلى الرغم من
التحذير من التطور التكنولوجي لكن لا
نستطيع اقفال اهميه التكنولوجيا في حياتنا
خصوصا في المجالين العلمي والطبي فبعد 12
عاما من الياس وعدم قدرته على المشي
استطاع رجل هولندي المشي مجددا بعد ان طور
باحثون جهاز الجسر الرقمي هذا الجهاز
عباره عن جهاز يكتشف النشاط العصبي عند
محاوله تحريك العضلات يتم تثبيته على
الدماغ ويقوم بقراءه خوارزميه معينه من
الدماغ ويحولها الى نبضات في العمود
الفقري ويقوم بتنشيط الاعصاب وتشغيل
العضلات لانتاج الحركه المقصوده صحيح ان
الجهاز لا ينتج حركه سريعه الى انه يسمح
بالحركات شبه طبيعيه يتم التحكم فيها من
خلال التفكير
اهلا بكم من جديد الاخبار المهمه العلميه
السعوديه في الفضاء والتي يقوم بها رائد
الفضاء السعوديين عالي القرني وريان
البرناوي برفقه اخرين ومهمتها اجراء اربع
عشره تجربه علميه وبحثيه في شتى المجالات
فامسم اجراء اتصال اللاسلكي بمحطه الفضاء
الدوليه من محطه ارضيه بالرياض تحدث داخل
لها مجموعه من الطلاب مع رائدى الفضاء علي
وريان متابع
[موسيقى]
الجهاز بمنطقه معينه لازم يكون منطقه
معينه عشان يسمعونا نسمع طيبه فوق المملكه
وبعدين لما يوصلون بالدائره اللي
قريبه من المملكه يشبك مع بعض
[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم
[تصفيق]
عظيمه جدا
انا مره فخوره اني كلمت رائده فضاء سعوديه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ويبدو ان هذه المهمه السعوديه اصبحت مصدر
الهام وفتحت الافاق وهو الساعات الطموحات
لداجي للشباب حيث
ظهر الطفل السعودي مشعل والذي يسمي نفسه
رائد فضاء المستقبل في فيديو تحدث فيه عن
حلمه بان يصبح رائد فضاء واكد انه سيكون
قادرا على تحقيق الحلم في المستقبل
ساذهب الى الفضاء فساد في
[موسيقى]
السطحون هناك سوى هناك
يوما ما سوتي ستصبح هناك
تجربه النوم هيا بنا
وقت
النوم الساعه
انهم ليست رئوي ولكن نحن
المصباح هناك في كوكب اللوم
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا وصلنا الى ختام حلقه اليوم من
تفاعلكم موعدكم الان مع فقره 25 سؤال وظيف
ساره دندراوي هذا الاسبوع النجمه حنان
مطاوعه اترككم مع هذه الفقره وتفاعلكم
يعود ويلقاكم الاحد مع ساره في امان الله
حنان مطاوع 25 سؤال لازم تجاوب عليهم
بسرعه ومن غير تفكير دور صنع اسمك
ساره
اكثر شيء يفشل في او يفشل الحب
الاعتياد
صفه اكتسبتيها من والدتك الفنانه سهير
المرشدي وصفه من والدك الراحل الفنان كرم
مطاوع من بابا الله يرحمه
المثابره واني اعرف اقول لا
حتى لو انا محتاجه اقول اه ماما اعتقد
بر الاقربون والعيله والحميميه هل وجدت
موهبه حنان طابع التقدير اللي بتستحقه
الحمد لله اه بالنسبه ليا مره في مره كده
يوم فيه بعد يوم مين هي نجمه تجيلك الاولى
من وجهه نظرك كثير
منى زكي هي سبقاني
هند صبري برضواني منه شلبي
اعتقد من اقدم ابرزهم بس في ناس تانيه
طالعه برضو متى تصيب النجوميه الفنان
بالجنون او الغرور
لما يبقى مش متزن ولما يبقى مش عارف ان كل
شيء الا زوال دور بتحلمي بتقديمه
مصر القديم عالم المصري القديم لانه شايف
فرعوني مثلا اوكي طيب حاولتي وانت بتكبري
انه الناس ما بتعرفي انه اهلك فنانين
مشهورين وعاندتي رغباتهم عشان تشقي طريق
بنفسك هل اليوم انت ندمانه كان مستاهل
الموضوع اه اوكي اكثر شيء تغير فيك بعد
ولاده بنتك اماليم كل حاجه كل حاجه كل
حاجه كل حاجه
حبيت الدنيا اكثر حبيت ان انا اعيش اكثر
بقى فارق معايا ان انا اعيش عشانها دور
ندمتي عليه
مش هقول اسمه طبعا عشان صنعه بس في مثلا
اتنين تلاته مش حباهم بس مش بسببي بسبب
انه الفن عمل جماعي انت بتبقي داخله
متخيله انما هنا يا اما هناك وفي الاخر حد
هو اللي بيبوظ لك الحكايه كلها طب قولي
اسم اوكي طيب اكبر تاثير لانفصال والديك
عليك
الصلابه اوكي تاثير ايجابي يعني اوكي اكثر
عيب يزعجك في زوجك
التدخين اوكي لو عندك مشكله مين اول وحده
ممكن تلجا لها في الوسط الفني عبد الغفور
من واحد لعشره قديش بتعاني من وسواس قهري
في موضوع النظافه ههه
15 اوكي ايش اهم نصيحه توجهيها لنفسك لو
رجع فيك الزمن
ما تقلقيش كله جاي
ليش السينما مش صحبه معاكي هي فين استني
ايه يا ساره ايه فين الصيني يا ساره اوكي
عيني حتى ما بيعجبك اللي بيتقدم حاليا لا
في حاجات بتقدم لطيفه بس في الاخر هي ندره
يعني فين ايام ما كنا بنعمل مثلا 50 فيلم
في السماء انت بتعملي كم دلوقتي سته سبعه
طيب ليش لما بتتخانقي بتستخدم اللغه
العربيه الفصحى
من بدايه السؤال عارفه هتكملي تقولي ايه
علشان
عشان بلاقي فيها
المعنى اللي انا عايزه اقوله
بانك تقدري توبخي اللي قدامك من غير ما
تجرحيم من غير ما تلفظي الفاظ نابيه او
انك تتدني بالحوار فهو تهزيء بس ايش تهزي
هو تهذيب
طيب صفه فيك نفسك ما توريها لبنتك الكسل
من قبل ما افكر العصبيه مع اني انا مش
بتعصب على الاخر قد ما انا بتعصب قوه
القوه الدربكه دربكه اه
وببين دايما الهدوء بس سؤال عندها الموضوع
مستنينا اهلا مين الفنان اللي نفسك تشتغلي
معاه
خالد النبوي منى زكي اوكي خلاص كفايه
البعض بيقول انك متخصصه في ادوار النكد
كيف تردي يا جماله يا جمال
رديتي على الموضوع اصلا اكثر حد بيضحك في
الدنيا بس يعني بتقدمي يمكن الادوار هذه
اللي فيها دراما باداء عالي مره فيمكن
عشان كده يا اختي عليك ربنا يخليك حاجه
احنا الشخصيات انطباعيه وكلي شي شويه اللي
هم القائمين على الصناعه فانت نجحت في
حاجه ما عندهمش اتساع افقي انهم يشوفوا
انك ممكن تبيعيه ومش عريضه انك تعملي ده
وده لا بيلعبوا في المضمون اوكي نجحتي
فهمت عليك طيب هل صحيح انه اجرك في العمل
بالملايين ههه ده اقل حاجه ههه
[ضحك]
هذا اهم شيء بس الان عاملين لنا ضغط يا
حنان يا حبيبتي هم طول الوقت عاملين لنا
ضغط لا مش بس ده الموضوع
الست
اه مطحونه مطحونه والراجل كمان على فكره
يعني انا شايفه انه الاثنين مطحونين بس هو
مجتمع
بيكيل بكيلين شويه صح اوكي لو انطلب منك
سيفي لك انت في ثلاثه ادوار بس تختاري اي
ثلاثه ادوار
مما عملت من اللي انت عملتيه
هذا المساء دور عبله سخيه
[موسيقى]
حلاوه الدنيا
اختيار حلو جدا اوكي سؤال نفسك من زمان اي
اعلامي يسالك هو ومن سالتيه
وحياتك مفكره ولا ما عندي شيء تحسي نفسي
يسالوني السؤال ده
هي المشكله في المباغته انك تساليني
السؤال ايه انت بتوهي الاجابه ايوه اه مش
كنت جلسه اه يمكن لو مخمخت حاجه اقول لك
فعلا ليه ما حدش سالني السؤال ده قبل كده
طيب خلاص خليني ابدل لك السؤال ده بتحبيني
ايوه جدا
شكرا شفتي خلصنا لا يا شيخ والله العظيم
ابص لك ولا لا لا يا شيخ بال 25 ولا سبعه
لازم 25 يا شيخه والله العظيم
ايه ده اه شفتي ولا فيه اي شيء ده ده مفيش
حاجه فعلا
[موسيقى]